and we're working
new leaked video showing a tense
confrontation between border patrol
agents and their chief during dhs
secretary alejandro mayorkas visit to
laredo texas this comes as kamala harris
admits it's going to take a quote long
period of time
to address the root causes of illegal
immigration
the work we need to do is going to be
work that will manifest over a long
period of time hopefully not too long
but certainly not overnight solutions if
they're going to have any impact will
not occur overnight
our next guest just returned from the
border where he learned about illegals
from illegals and migrants about the
dangers cartels are presented u.s senate
candidate for ohio bernie moreno joins
us now bernie thanks for being here
thanks for making the trip if you would
you've got border patrol agents in
revolt because they're not allowed to do
their job you've got kamala harris
saying it's all about root causes but
it's going to take a while
when you're down there what do you see
well she's exactly wrong you can't solve
a problem by ignoring it she's never
even been there the reality is the
border patrol agents aren't asking for
more resources they're not even asking
for more people what they want is good
policy and these policies can happen
overnight we can fix the problem but
she's your typical politician that won't
go down there and actually talk to the
front line people that's why i went down
there these things could be fixed pete
we need to we need to defend our country
and we need to insist that leaders
defend us and keep us safe
well i'm told what you saw down there
was harrowing cartels
rapes
you know what or at least word of those
things what did you see as far as right
now on the border what the cartels are
doing
well what what we're doing what the
policies that joe biden are doing is
absolutely devastating to these migrants
they go through a terrible journey the
women are raped 12 year old girls are
forced to take birth control because
they know they're going to be raped
along the journey women are the women we
met had been sexually assaulted the men
had been beaten and held at gunpoint
they got charged a river tax for
crossing into our country we cannot
allow that kind of destruction of
humanity to occur because of our bad
policies and again these things can be
fixed it's not complicated it's common
sense
that's exactly right that's why what
kamala harris said has been a sham from
the beginning it's a sham today what i
respect a lot more are the guys and gals
on the border actually doing the job you
saw that revolt to the border chief
there is that in keeping with what you
heard as well from border patrol agents
that they're chomping to do their job
it's just
it is it's we know the political
leadership is failing them is the
leadership of the border patrol at the
top complicit because they're willing to
go along with policies they know don't
work
well i think they're put in a very tough
situation because the policies don't
come from them the policies come right
out of washington d.c this is
intentional we're using these migrants
as political pawns
to create what they want which is a
different voter a different demographic
in america the border patrol agent that
we met with himself had captured one
person with enough fentanyl on him to
kill 450 000 people just one out of what
he estimates is a million that got away
so a million that got away our country
is in grave danger we're being invaded
our southern border and and joe biden is
more concerned about the ukraine border
than our own border we have to make this
a top priority
amen if we don't have a border we don't
have a country as donald trump talked
about and right now we don't have one
yet we're obsessed with one halfway
around the world uh
bernie moreno you run for the senate in
ohio thank you very much for joining us
this morning for going down the border
and actually caring about it which is
all we want from our leaders and we're
certainly not getting right now thank
you bernie